LFO singer Devon Lima has died after a  year-long battle with cancer he was 41  years old  Lima joined the group in 1999 that same  year they released summer girls the  smash hit was followed by many more like  West Side Story girl on TV and every  other time  talk about  sadly in 2010 member Richard Cronin died  from a stroke related to leukemia he was  diagnosed in 2005 the two remaining  members reunited just last year and  planned to go on tour they released a  new song titled perfect 10 but things  were put on hold when Devin was  diagnosed with stage 4 adrenal cancer  but the pain only kicked in  try different things to go away it's  just time to go in I'll see you on the  other side  the duo shared Devin's progress with  fans in a series of videos - one kidney  but you're still beautiful  thanks for all your thoughts and prayers  you love you feel it over here I love  you I love this planet I love all my  parents and sisters whoa  [Music]